Imagine trying to run one of those 48-hour red-bulb-fueled tech hackathons.
Oh yeah, pure chaos.
Right, but imagine every single line of code you write has to pass strict federal accessibility laws,
algorithmic transparency audits, and like national security checks.
That is definitely not your typical hackathon vibe.
No, usually when we think of hackathons, we picture a move fast and break things environment.
You know, you ignore the rules, bypass all the standard red tape,
and just focus on getting a flashy prototype barely working by Sunday afternoon.
Exactly. And in the traditional startup world, bypassing those procedures is almost like a
badge of honor. Oh, totally.
You're practically rewarded for the illusion of functionality.
Just make it look good for the judges.
But what happens when you take that unstructured chaotic energy and drop it straight into the
public sector? A place that is, well, literally defined by uncompromising transparency laws
and incredibly tight security rules.
Yeah, and that is exactly the collision we're exploring with you today.
We're looking at a really unique document.
It's a deep research review of the AI engineering lab hackathon London 2026 repository.
And we aren't just looking at a summary or a blog post here.
We are looking at the actual living GitHub repository used to run this event.
Which is wild.
It is. We can trace its entire DNA through its commit history.
It's honestly fascinating to see it evolve in real time.
Yeah.
Like back on April 8th, it was just this skeletal event brief, just a basic reademi file.
Right, super bare bones.
But then on April 14th, the organizers pushed this massive commit.
They loaded it up with detailed challenge briefs,
synthetic data sets, and incredibly specific setup guides.
And the craziest part is the timing.
Yes. Because literally today, April 15th, 2026, we can see the day of cleanup happening live.
Yeah, they just deleted an outdated participant handout file
and trimmed the re-data me to reflect the live event.
I mean, we are analyzing a project while it's still breathing.
And that timing gives us a really profound advantage.
By analyzing this repository in its current executed state,
we get a front row seat to a much larger paradigm shift.
A shift in how large organizations are basically forcing AI to mature.
Exactly.
And that is our mission for this deep dive.
We're extracting the most valuable insights from this repo
to understand how AI is fundamentally changing software delivery
in high stakes, highly regulated environments.
That's a huge topic.
Okay, let's unpack this.
Because reading through this research review,
the core philosophy of this event completely caught me off guard.
It is certainly a massive rejection of your standard AI event, that's for sure.
Yeah.
The fundamental difference here is the objective itself.
I mean, most hackathons happening right now are totally obsessed with the what.
Like can your team bolt an AI chatbot onto an existing database?
Right.
Or can you make a large language model generate a functional web app in 10 seconds?
Just flashy tricks.
But this government event explicitly does not care about the what.
It is entirely focused on how?
The actual process.
Yes.
How do AI coding assistants change the daily, unglamorous practices of software delivery?
It's about the engineering lifecycle, not just a shiny final feature.
So if the standard is that high,
you obviously can't just ask these teams to build a simple to do app.
No, definitely not.
But before we get into what they're actually building,
we have to look at the guard rails surrounding the participants.
Because in a normal hackathon, rules are just red tape.
You read them once maybe and ignore them.
Pretty much.
But here the rules act as the primary design constraints.
Yeah.
The source material actually refers to this as design pressure.
Design pressure.
I like that.
And that pressure is applied through very specific,
non-negotiable public sector standards.
Which are intense.
Oh, absolutely.
We're talking about the GOV.UK service standard,
which mandates solving whole problems for users
rather than just shipping isolated features.
Right.
Teams must adhere to WCAG 2.2WA.
That's the web content accessibility guidelines.
Plus the government's AI playbook.
Yes.
And the data and AI ethics framework,
the algorithmic transparency recording standard.
And on top of all of that,
the UK's National Cyber Security Center, or NCSC,
secure by design principles.
OK.
I have to push back on the practicality of that,
just looking at the timeline.
Fair enough.
I mean, in a one-day time crunch,
aren't those heavy institutional standards
going to completely suffocate innovation?
It sounds like it, right?
It feels like being on a competitive cooking show
where you only have 30 minutes to make a gourmet meal.
But if you don't follow rigorous, multi-step,
commercial food safety laws,
your dish goes straight in the trash,
no matter how good it tastes.
What's fascinating here is that
suffocation is actually the goal.
Wait, really?
Yes, it kills a very specific kind of innovation.
The useless kind.
Oh, I see.
The repository is acting as what the research is called,
a beta operating model.
By enforcing these really heavy standards
in a compressed time frame,
the organizers are actively separating
sustainable engineering from mere flashy AI automation.
Okay, so give me an example of how that plays out.
Well, let's say a team uses an AI assistant
to spin up a slick working portal in two hours.
Sounds like a win.
Right.
But if a blind citizen using a screen reader
can't navigate that portal because the AI generated sloppy HTML structure...
Oh, the WCAG failure.
Exactly.
Or if the team can't prove exactly where the AI pulled its data from,
that's data provenance,
the prototype is considered a failure.
Wow.
You might look great in a demo,
but it completely fails as a viable public sector tool.
So the constraints actually forced the AI to write better architecture,
not just faster code.
I love that.
That a brilliant way to test the tools.
Yeah, if those are the rules of the kitchen,
what exactly are these teams being asked to cook?
Because the repo outlines four distinct challenges,
and I noticed they aren't just repetitive variations of build a chatbot.
Not all.
Let me run through the first one.
Challenge one is all about transforming a standard static PDF
like a sample license application into an accessible digital service.
And to be clear in the mechanics of that,
the expectation isn't just running simple optical character recognition,
or OCR, on a PDF to scrape the text.
Right, because that's too easy.
The developers have to use their AI assistance to build complete,
accessible form journeys.
Which is incredibly tedious to do manually.
Yeah, that means generating code for proper state management,
robust validation loops, so users actually know when they've made an error,
and a final check answer's page.
And it all has to be strictly aligned to gov.uk design patterns.
It basically forces the AI coding tools to prove they can handle
the necessary scaffolding of public infrastructure,
rather than just generating a clever algorithm.
Then there's challenge two, which focuses on unlocking dark data.
And I was completely geeking out over this one.
It's so good.
If you've ever tried to search your own company's disorganized shared drive,
you know exactly how painful this scenario is.
Oh yeah, we've all been there.
The starter data the organizers provided is intentionally wonderfully messy.
Highly realistic, in other words.
Exactly, they gave teams 20 structured files and 23 binary files,
simulating a totally chaotic departmental network drive.
And they built in deliberate operational contradictions.
Yeah, I would look closely at the architecture of that mess,
because it is brilliant.
They included a file named DOCHB003 that explicitly claims,
inside its text, that its status is current.
Right.
But sitting right next to it in the directory is a newer file.
DOC-HB009, which states in its metadata that it replaces that earlier version.
Which creates a massive trap for a lazy AI system.
A huge trap.
The follow on training value of challenge two is immense,
because it forces teams to confront real world extraction and versioning conflicts.
So if a citizen asks an AI portal for the current policy on a specific grant.
Right, and if the team built a basic retrieval augmented generation system,
like a standard R system, that just searches for keywords,
the AI might grab DOCHB003.
Just because it sees the word current.
Exactly, and it confidently delivers outdated wrong information.
In government, the standard for data isn't just it sounds plausible.
Right, it has to be legally accurate.
It must be proven to be right.
And the human operator must be able to trace exactly how the system arrived at that conclusion.
Here's where it gets really interesting though.
When we look at challenge three,
which is about supporting casework decisions and challenge four,
organization insight, the repository introduces a massive twist.
The DPI twist.
Yeah, it explicitly says they do not provide central model API access for this hackathon.
Teams are instructed to use mocked AI capabilities for things like casework support.
Which is definitely surprising.
Meaning they aren't hooking up to a live large language model
to process the data.
They were just hard coding simulated responses.
Isn't mocking the AI kind of missing the point at an AI engineering event?
On the surface, yes, it feels like cheating.
But the research review highlights this as the single strongest design choice
in the entire repository.
Why?
We have to look at what they are actually testing.
It's like testing the aerodynamics of a car chassis in a wind tunnel
before you've even built the engine.
Oh, I like that.
You are testing the structural integrity of the frame, not the horsepower.
Okay, the wind tunnel metaphor tracks perfectly.
So by using a mocked AI that just spits out a pre-programmed decision,
the judges are looking entirely at the workflow built around that decision.
Exactly.
They are evaluating the team's algorithmic transparency.
If an AI system simulated or real recommends denying a citizen's application,
the critical engineering problem is the human containment field.
The human containment field, that's a great term.
How does the human case worker review that recommendation?
What specific logs are generated?
Is the user interface designed in a way that allows the human to easily override the AI?
Or does it passively encourage them to just lazily click approve?
Exactly.
It tests the accountability mechanisms.
So if you don't have the engine of the AI,
you can still perfectly engineer the dashboard and the brakes.
Precisely.
It ensures teams aren't just letting a black box model
make unverified decisions about a citizen's livelihood
without an ironclad audit trail.
That makes total sex.
And from a purely logistical standpoint,
it allows judges to evaluate public sector delivery practice
without penalizing a team that might run into API rate limits
or latency issues on a busy Saturday afternoon.
Right, because APIs crash all the time during hackathons.
Exactly.
The focus days relentlessly on human accountability.
So those four challenges make up the highly structured menu.
But what happens when a team of engineers looks at that menu
and decides they want to go entirely off script?
Well, they actually plan for that.
Yeah, the repo includes an open brief route.
Teams can bring their own wild ideas,
but there are three rigid stipulations.
They have to prove a real user need.
They're absolutely forbidden from using live personal data.
And they need a functional prototype
ready to demo by 15,000.
The open brief allows for necessary creativity, sure.
But the research points out a severe operational risk here.
Scope creep.
Massively.
While the concept of an open brief is sound,
operationally, it is what the review calls under-instrumented.
When you let developers lose with AI tools,
the scope can expand dangerously fast.
This raises an important question, though.
How do you safely triage a room
full of unpredictable AI experiments in just a few hours?
You force a bottleneck.
Ah!
That is why the repository mandates
a strict facilitator conversation
before 10 0 0 a.m.
for anyone attempting the open brief.
The 10 0 0 a.m. triage
walk me through the friction of that process.
Like what exactly are the facilitators looking to shut down?
They are hunting for unsafe architectural patterns
and scoping delusions.
So it's going delusions, yeah.
Let's say a team proposes a system
that ingests live ministerial emails
to predict policy changes.
Oh boy.
Right, the facilitator shuts that down immediately.
Not just because the immense security risk,
but because building a secure ingestion pipeline
for classified data cannot be done legally
or safely in a single day.
So the team is forced to pivot
to using synthetic dummy data
or publicly available guidance.
Exactly.
The facilitators ensure the project
solves a tangible user problem safely,
legally, and within a six-hour window.
It's that design pressure again.
The organizers are saying,
"Look, you can build whatever you want
as long as it survives contact with reality by 3 p.m."
Which is a very hard deadline.
So to execute all of this,
who is actually sitting in the room
and what tools are they using?
If we look at the domain mapping file,
it gives us a clear look at the attendee mix
and it is not a room full of novices.
Hopefully not.
We're seeing heavy hitters from across the government,
the home office, HM revenue and customs,
the Ministry of Justice, the DVLA, the Met Office.
And we know they understand the stakes
because many of these specific departments
already have highly public algorithmic
transparency recording standard or ATRS records for AI.
They have already deployed into production.
Right.
Like HMRC already has public records
for a VHE return analysis tool that helps with compliance.
Yes.
And the DVLA has detailed records
for a contact center chatbot
and a medical casework decision tree system.
So these attendees aren't just playing with new toys.
They know exactly how punishing a failed deployment can be.
They've lived it.
So with that level of talent,
what specific AI coding assistants are they typing into?
The setup guide is technically tool agnostic,
but it explicitly names four heavyweights.
GitHub co-pilot, Amazon hero, Gemini code assist,
and Amazon Q developer.
Usually this is where the tech industry
devolves into a completely pointless debate
over which underlying large language model is the smartest.
Oh, the endless benchmark arguments.
Right.
But the research review makes a crucial pivot here.
It argues that for an enterprise level event like this,
abstract model intelligence is almost irrelevant.
Really irrelevant.
It is entirely about workflow fit.
Okay.
How does the architecture of the AI tool
mesh with the specific engineering rhythm of the team using it?
Well, I noticed Gemini codices is specifically favored
in the research for its cited contextual responses.
Yes.
Which makes total sense for a government environment.
I mean, if you're writing software that processes tax returns
and the AI suggests that a block of code,
you need a paper trail.
You need the AI to cite exactly which documentation or code base
it pulled that pattern from.
Rather than just hallucinating a clever solution.
Exactly.
And that is the exact mechanism
that makes Gemini valuable there.
Now consider a team with a totally different engineering culture.
Maybe one heavily focused on writing exhaustive specifications
before they read a single line of code.
For them, Amazon Kiro is positioned as the ideal tool.
Yes.
Kiro acts as an agent to coding environment.
It's actually designed to ingest and read comprehensive requirements,
map out the architecture,
and then generate syntax that strictly adheres to that initial spec.
So Kiro isn't just auto completing your typing.
It's acting almost like a junior developer reading a brief.
What about GitHub co-pilot and Amazon Q?
Well, co-pilot remains the strongest bet
for teams looking for low friction immediate flow
right inside their code editor.
Fast and responsive.
Yeah.
It's about speed and maintain the developer's momentum
without switching windows.
Amazon Q developer, on the other hand,
is the obvious choice if your team is already building inside
an AWS shaped cloud environment.
Because it knows the neighborhood, basically.
Exactly.
Its architecture excels at understanding AWS specific build,
troubleshoot, and operate flows.
It understands the ecosystem it lives in.
So the secret isn't picking the "best AI."
It's picking the tool,
whose internal architecture matches your team's external processes.
Precisely.
But the review also points out something incredibly humbling
for the less experienced teams in the room.
It explicitly states that the biggest productivity boost
won't actually come from which of those four tools they select.
Not at all.
For novices, the critical edge comes from fundamental prompt hygiene,
the use of context files, and decomposition discipline.
Decomposition discipline,
meaning the ability of the human developer
to break a massive software problem down into tiny,
isolated, testable chunks before ever asking the AI for help.
Yes.
Because if you ask an AI to build a secure login portal,
it will guess at 1,000 variables
and likely give you a bloated, insecure mess.
Right.
But if you break it down and ask it to write a function
that validates a 12-character alphanumeric string
against these three specific rules, you get pristine code.
And you also have to supply the AI with context files,
giving it the exact design guidelines
or existing code-based rules it needs to follow.
Exactly.
If you lack that discipline, it truly does not matter
if you have the most advanced coding assistant on the planet.
You are simply going to generate bad code faster.
Generating bad code faster.
Wow.
That is the terrifying underside of this whole AI boom.
If you don't understand the mechanisms,
the AI just scales your incompetence.
It really does.
Which brings us to the broader implications of all this.
So what does this all mean for you?
Whether you're a developer inside a massive government agency,
a startup founder trying to scale,
or to someone trying to understand
where the technology industry is heading next week.
The takeaway is massive.
The overarching theme from this deep research review
is that this hackathon repository
is not just a schedule of events.
By front-loading it with stringent judging rubrics
and designing it to convert team patterns
into reusable templates after the event concludes.
It transforms.
Yes, it becomes a highly valuable
cross-government training asset
for the entire AI software development lifecycle.
It's a blueprint.
It fundamentally redefines the concept of good enough
in the modern age of AI engineering.
Ten years ago, a successful hackathon demo
was simply proving that a novel feature
could compile and run.
Yeah, that was enough.
Today, a strong demo,
especially when public infrastructure is involved,
demands that you show the judges exactly where your system fails.
You have to map the edges of the cliff.
Exactly.
You must demonstrate the exact boundary
where the AI's confidence drops,
where it stops processing,
and where the human operator is forced to take over.
So if you present a slick interface,
but you can't show the judges the human review loop,
or the audit logs of what the human overruled,
your demo is considered weak.
The engineering challenge is no longer
about maximizing automation.
It's about maximizing accountability.
It's not about replacing the human.
It's about building a perfectly documented,
incredibly powerful sidekick for the human,
and knowing exactly when to put that sidekick in time out.
We've watched the culture shift from the wild west
of unregulated hackathons
into an era of precision engineering under intense scrutiny,
which leaves us with a final thought for you to mull over today.
Let's hear it.
If this one-day government event
is specifically designed to expose
how AI coding assistants are permanently altering
the mechanics of software delivery,
ask yourself this.
If we were to comprehensively audit
your own team's code repository right now,
would we see a clear, impenetrable boundary
between human accountability and AI automation?
Or are the two already inextricably
and perhaps unsafely blurred?
A question every single engineering team needs
to answer before they push their next update.
Absolutely. Until next time.